E aí
oi oi
se faltar algum tempo que eu fui chamado
pela primeira vez já te vista bem talvez
alguém tenha se perguntado aqui na
plateia ou do outro lado da tela será
que ele é um desocupado fato é que
existe muito preconceito eu digo até
preconceitos com essas palavras ativismo
militância e no início Nem eu mesmo
entende o que significava o cerne da
palavra ativismo significação que eu que
vocês podem fazer através de ações
práticas e que impactem a mim a minha
comunidade a cidade o nosso país e não
seria prepotência dizer o nosso planeta
e com base nisso e através de vários
temas que eu tenho muito interesse só
apaixonado Eu Escolhi meio ambiente
talvez por causa de memórias como essa
eu com 34 anos nos dias mais frios de
inverno com a promessa de que caíram
pinhões de um Pinheiro na propriedade
dos meus avós bem não era todos os anos
que essa promessa era entregue e não era
todos os anos quer ver um pinhões talvez
aí nasce uma semente lidar com
frustrações e os nãos' que eu ouviria no
futuro mas houveram também proposições
muito positivas para mim até lembranças
muito positivas eu tive a oportunidade
de estudar na melhor escola da minha
cidade e para ensino médio nós temos
apenas uma escola em Atalanta que é de
onde eu venho 6 mil habitantes uma
comunidade agrícola mas com jovens com
muita vontade de fazer a diferença de
serem protagonistas e de protagonizarem
alguma mudança em suas comunidades
e com base nisso e também graças à
escuta dos professores da diretora e da
primavera organização ambientalista que
atua lá em Atalanta nós fundamos em 2016
e plantando o futuro um coletivo de
jovens ambientalistas que de início nem
tinha uma ideia do que ia fazer
começamos ajudando a escola deixar de
jardins [ __ ] plantar uma muda
outra de árvore com proprietários
parceiros e isso deu muito certo porque
além do impacto no meio ambiente nós
tivemos mais pessoas querendo participar
do projeto plantando o futuro cresceu e
a partir disso nós ouvimos também muitos
nãos Como já comentei com vocês algumas
pessoas que até se opuseram ao projeto
interpretaram errado nossos objetivos
mas esse jogo começou a virar com uma
situação inusitada ano passado né porque
das queimadas da Amazônia nós poderíamos
uma mobilização muito simples lá no
pátio
é mas que foi parar no mapa do fridays
for Future ou cestas pelo futuro o
movimento Global hidráulico por uma
jovem sueca greta Tambau que busca a
participação protagonismo de jovens
perante a crise climática o nosso lema é
se não tem um futuro para nós Porque nós
estamos indo para a escola então o nosso
mote é pelo menos uma vez por mês em
Atalanta fazer mobilizações da própria
escola conversando com professores com a
comunidade ouvindo os fatos científicos
de impacto no planeta e também como a
crise climática Impacto as nossas
cidades
Oi e aí dentro desse folder dentro desse
mapa do Freddy creature feature a nossa
ação foi parar no história da Gisele
Bündchen bem enquanto metade de Atalanta
se perguntava por que a falante está no
história da Gisele Bündchen Metade dos
seguidores dela Provavelmente
perguntavam o que era tá lenta e a
partir daí muitas pessoas da nossa
comunidade passaram a apoiar o projeto
só no ano passado nós fizemos além
destas são outras 15 do fridays for
Future em Atalanta oito ações de plantio
de mão na terra na cidade na região ou
37 ações de educação ambiental com
crianças e três ações de conversa com
líderes locais e deles comunitários como
prefeitos vereadores e presidentes de
associações
e eu tive também ano passado a
oportunidade de integrar uma outra rede
um outro coletivo de movimento que
chegava aqui no Brasil os jovens
transformadores da choca ashoka uma
organização que também nasceu buscando
dar voz a protagonismo em 1980 do outro
lado do mundo lá na Índia o Bill drayton
esse cara da imagem acima fazer muitas
viagens até a Índia ele americano porque
era um executivo da Mackenzie e na Índia
alivia muitos bons projectos
relativamente simples mas que tinha um
impacto muito grande nas comunidades
onde eles atuavam e ao mesmo passo não
tinha nenhum apoio nem de organizações
governamentais nem do terceiro setor
então o Bill fez um projeto de início
muito pequeno para dar voz apoio e
formação essas pessoas em 2020 ashoka
tem quase quatro mil associados ao redor
do mundo e quase 400 No Brasil onde ela
chegou em 85
Oi e o primeiro fellow da ashoka aqui
foi Chico Mendes infelizmente no mesmo
ano onde ele foi a leite pela choca foi
assassinado por causa do trabalho
diuturno de ativismo perante os
seringais e dos extrativistas da
Amazônia nós temos outros exemplos da
choca também aqui no Brasil com
Wellington Nogueira do doutores da
alegria que leva espetáculos de circo
para leitos de hospitais aqui no Brasil
temos também a Raquel Rosenberg
fundadora do maior coletivo de jovens no
Brasil o engajamundo ou aqui em Santa
Catarina Thaíse guzzatti que a fundador
e idealizador do acolhida na colônia um
projeto que mudou a realidade econômica
e também social de centenas de
trabalhadores rurais desde o início
deste século
bom e com base nisso com esses novos
jovens que foram eleitos pelo programa
nós temos a foto aqui no slide nós temos
contato com outros jovens de outras
realidades do mundo inteiro e nós
tentamos entender o que faz pessoas
serem protagonistas ser a empatia será
os problemas que cada um enfrenta
sinceramente nós não temos a resposta
mas eu acho que me cabe aqui no tempo
que ainda resta contar alguns desses
bons exemplos dos projetos e eu vou
iniciar com a Carla em Manaus ela sempre
gostou muito de astronomia de filmes que
tinham como tema o espaço até aí tudo
bem realidade de milhares de crianças e
a Carla também na escola sempre foi
muito incentivado a participar de
olimpíadas de astronomia e astrofísica e
sempre se saiu muito bem era medalhista
o que incomodava a Carla era que outros
jovens não tinham um desempenho tão
bacana quanto ela então 2017
e com ajuda de amigos da escola ela
fundou o projeto Cosmos que leva
oficinas e também aulas gratuitas de
astronomia e astrofísica das escolas
ribeirinhas de Manaus e daquela região
muitas vezes utilizando um barco como
meio de transporte horas a fio para
chegar nas comunidades e também uma
barraca como dormitório
e a 3.000 quilômetros dali no sertão
Pernambucano nós temos Luan São Bento do
Una ele também trabalha com o meio
ambiente mas em um contexto geográfico
totalmente diferente o Luan fez um
mapeamento de todas as árvores
frutíferas da cidade dele realizou o
plantio de outras mudas e mapeou esse
mapa as tanto físicos quanto digitais
através de um aplicativo que ele mesmo
idealizou porque o problema do Luan o
que fez ele tomar essa iniciativa era de
que muitas pessoas não tinham dinheiro
para conseguir comprar comida de
qualidade e também produtos saudáveis
então Através disso ele impacta
diretamente comunidades famílias que
agora tem uma piadas essas espécies
essas mudas sabem ao certo quando que
será um frutíferas quando que é possível
fazer a colheita e também Ele criou uma
espécie de comunidade muito mais
integrada do que se podia ver antes do
projeto
o e descendo um pouco mapa do Brasil que
é tão vasto e tão grande eu não poderia
deixar de falar da Isabelle de São Paulo
capital a Isabelle sempre foi muito
ligada com tecnologia e sempre foi muito
inteligente tanto é que conseguiu bolsa
para um dos colégios mais celetistas de
São Paulo e o problema da Isabelle era
que ela não via meninas como ela em
posição de destaque não via professoras
diretoras e diretores de empresas E aí
ela fundou o projeto meninas negras para
levar jovens como ela da comunidade dela
para oportunidades incríveis de formação
de capacitação estágios Denise empresas
muito grandes como a Microsoft EA Oracle
ou a Google por exemplo
ó e esses três projetos São só alguns
dos que eu poderia contar aqui para
vocês ou melhor ainda que eu poder pedir
para vocês da plateia para vocês do
outro lado da tela contarem para nós
porque isso é uma constante no Brasil na
estampado nos jornais nas telas de
televisão e mais do que isso o que
talvez incomode um pouco é que embora
seja até um presente tão perto da nossa
realidade parece que é necessário um
ingrediente especial para ver esse
protagonismo para ações como esta
acontecerem e talvez haja através dessas
são aqui onde nós promovemos o diálogo
com mais de 100 jovens lá de Atalanta
promovendo agricultura sustentável
agricultura orgânica talvez eu entendi
que esse ingrediente especial e secreto
de certo modo seja diálogo outros diriam
que a empatia
Oi e eu gostaria de pedir também para
vocês entenderem Qual é a motivação para
estar aqui no Ted hoje ouvindo o
contando boas histórias para colocar um
sorriso no rosto início do dia e cumprir
a jornada de trabalho ou para ter
escolhido essa profissão por exemplo se
isso de algum modo está conectado com
uma qualidade de vida melhor para você
ou para sua comunidade da sua cidade ou
para as pessoas que vocês dão eu tenho
que dizer que vocês são jovens pouco me
importa aqui na afirmação a idade que
vocês têm ou o que está estampado nos
documentos de vocês vocês são jovens
porque vocês acreditam no bem comum e
vocês são jovens Porque apesar de tudo
alguns digam que até flertando com a
ingenuidade Vocês acreditam que esse
futuro melhor é possível
E aí antes de acabar aqui a minha
apresentação eu tenho que dizer que
ativismo é necessário e que nesse exato
momento a centenas de unidades de
conservação que de certo modo é até uma
ironia porque uma sociedade que precisa
criar espaços isolados que a proteger a
natureza de si mesma não pode estar
certa é situações como esta aqui em
março uma unidade de conservação ou de
Atalanta da minha cidade ficou com seu
ponto turístico principal sem cair uma
gota d'água a Cachoeira perau do golpe e
existem centenas de outras situações
como essa aqui em Rio do Sul ou de onde
as pessoas estão assistindo de atividade
humana empatando seriamente a nossa
própria vida mas também do meio ambiente
de centenas de espécies
e eu termino aqui falando que nós
precisamos talvez encontrar a esperança
antes de tudo porque isso é mais difícil
do que a mudança que nós precisamos
fazer ele e se ainda me a tempo restante
eu preciso dizer que nesse exato momento
Chamas consomem todos os idiomas do
Brasil mas de forma especial a Amazônia
e nas últimas semanas do Pantanal nesse
exato momento também a centenas de
ativistas milhares de ativistas
protegendo essas áreas os povos
originarios os brigadistas os ativistas
veterinários que estavam os animais tudo
isso por causa das chamas que destroem
tudo que está à frente dela e por causa
disso faça uma singela homenagem de um
poeta Pantaneiro Manoel de Barros que
dizia assim tudo que o homem cria vira
sucata o carro a bicicleta o avião o que
não vira açúcar até a terra a árvore
a água a tartaruga até nave espacial
vira sucata e entre uma nave espacial e
uma garça branca de pelugem Alva do
Pantanal uma garça É muito mais bela e
peço desculpas para a sociedade por
cometer essa verdade a que eu não pego
uma oposição entre tecnologia e
atividade humana e natureza mas que a
gente possa cada vez mais ser integrados
e entender que o nosso destino em nossas
atitudes não impactam apenas a minha
história ou da minha comunidade mas é de
todos que vivem aqui e de todo esse
planeta que o futuro seja de cada vez
mais ativismo sim muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
E aí
G1